Hey all right but is Purana back welcome
back to bully are you ready to bully
some people we don't bully people we are
nice paper bullying is bad either way
we're gonna go to chemistry class but
that's good good people do like me why
don't you like chemistry I think I
prefer math or physics
a bit more though oh all right
penis snob big dinosaur elephant
elephant i mean snake
we're under snake dynamite what a blah
what yeah I passed that [ __ ] wow that's
a short class is that it that really why
does he always do that alright so now we
can make firecrackers let's [ __ ] it you
okay oh girl go what stop I don't have
time for you I'm hot I'm heading on
girls [ __ ] hey hey guy
best best hit can you stop can everyone
stop [ __ ] with me stop [ __ ] with
me
[ __ ] you off [ __ ] jesus [ __ ] christ
all right I'm out of here
you're all [ __ ] up yeah I'll [ __ ] up
man all right let's go to the star on
the mini-map all right here's my wonder
go I don't know you [ __ ] Casanova
well is this pants open that's [ __ ]
disgusting look at that [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] open no uh you bros if you ever
want to hit a girl just ask her if she
likes stuff that's this fantastic or if
you want to make out
all right let's we're gonna start on you
it's [ __ ] pants man Jesus I hope no
one like that excuse in real comfortable
here my boy like fighting by making a
nuisance of yourself that is not the
Bullworth way boy yeah you could have
fooled me
yeah what I said you could have fooled
me this place is full of bullies and
maniacs wellies that's just school
spirit kind hijinx like a midnight we
felt nothing of castrating the new boys
castrating the new boy nonsense Hopkins
I want you to behave yourself you might
learn something
don't castrate anyone else sir on your
way what the [ __ ] hey I saw you sucking
up to Crabill snitch what the hell oh
you don't know you don't hit my nap on
oh you're going down like dead [ __ ]
come I don't know all right let's get
this [ __ ] I'm not a wimp
I got this [ __ ] why are they following
him
hey hey okay I guess I gotta follow this
tap repeatedly what I did say I didn't
Kasia no come on you [ __ ] idiot
okay so if I tap it he runs even faster
is that it
it's not a Stefano statue better be
otherwise is not the official bro
Academy what's up
whoa once y'all killing these [ __ ]
they're all set
alright I don't even have to fight them
I show I throw a [ __ ] dynamite
interface what a good way to kill paper
hey what's up I want to say something
bad that this is our Hillary really live
in box if we just [ __ ] just [ __ ]
night oh well maybe how to drink oh [ __ ]
alright what do you want
ah come on dude chill out
I throw a [ __ ] dynamite in the face
whoa two at a time all right how about
the one at a time ladies I know you like
me at all but I will [ __ ] you all whoa
you don't [ __ ] with pens I know secret
ninja karate skills parents have you
seen my skills I call them the skills in
the press with a pill poor guy ah all
right [ __ ] it
ah what's going on i shooting Step five
all right whoa that's right [ __ ]
but it is a UFO I picked this okay Davis
you are going to die just like I don't
know [ __ ] it I don't care
here you go Davis Rock whoa he's like I
went about he saw it you saw it
Jason that's what you get yeah he did it
I thought he wasn't gonna do it all
right so now we got a [ __ ] slingshot
I don't know what are we gonna do with
that faction all right so you doesn't
like us now well we don't like barrels
anyways
all right [ __ ] why did how do they go
but how did they go all right let's hit
on their girl sit down there girl come
on
it's called shoes I don't know if you're
familiar with
anyone ever tell you you're what son
oh you don't dump in that side you
better run [ __ ] out oh [ __ ] stink bomb
away kids is out of here whoa hey what's
up
whoops sorry it's all right
that wasn't me I lost that [ __ ] I run
the column nah oh what's up girl you're
gonna [ __ ] love the pickup lines
they're like the best thing ever
they wasn't Oh Brooke I can breath his
paper hey sup professed oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry no no no I try to
provide that was a brofist oh we have to
go to English class he doesn't care
about me punching people you just want
me to go to class huh okay that's good
that's a good attitude hey you should
usually do that in real life to fun
things first and then what is this I
have to collect a word is that it mmm no
oh good show good [ __ ] do I just make a
tiny word out of this or do I have to
fill out of the letter I don't think I
can do anything
okay okay no oh no no that isn't exist
low access however go down this right
that is right does meow exist I don't
think so
holy [ __ ] it does all right how about
I'd wrote well emo I don't know help my
brother says I'm not English I don't
know this that's not English
come on it is you know it is a Mau Mau
ball from Mel oh hello mo no that has to
be some sort of slang yes that's a
Swedish way icon
I'm gonna guess on you knew was actually
a thing all right so
yes I got one the last second Mao I have
no whatever that's really nice from a
teacher to say oh well well I tried so
hard
Curnow Channel oh let's loot this guy's
rot Locker oh I can hide in lockers all
right
[ __ ] yeah big lockers in America our
lockers are kind of small and we have
winter jackets where the jacket don't
fit the lockers I'm just saying all
right I guess what are they good nerds
oh well I consider myself very much a
nerd my myself sir if I ever make fun of
nerds I'm literally just making fun of
myself so don't be don't be offended by
that all right we should save actually
all right and then we start a new
mission here we go slingshot mission
that's a good idea
he's a really good actor my opinion it's
a believable character someone not much
I was just telling PD here about my idea
to take over the school I mean my plan
will us to take over the school that
whether don't worry Jimmy it's just a
little something I came up with a gank
or swim my friend and if you're good at
swimming
she gotta let the losers drown what what
what what what duh
anything else yeah yes I know what PTU
bite jimmy is pretty dumb Oh Jimmy what
that mark no all I said was that you had
to be pretty dumb to get expelled from
so many schools oh no you don't know
that James all he said was that you must
be dumb or maybe you're all messed up
because he came from a broken home what
just about meet war come on dude this
ain't all lining everything out
texts man whoa not cool man Dosher PD
oh [ __ ] you lie because you know what
happens to liars no no I'm not lying
okay
oh come on Jimmy let's go see how good
you are with this new slingshot I heard
you how the hell did he know about the
slingshot nothing escapes my notice ah
okay everything that's kind of creepy we
can do like gay marriage uh I got peed
in the back I went to [ __ ] poor guy no
one gives a [ __ ] I give a [ __ ] about
Petey that makes me a good person I do
quite frankly think so alright we are
going to that cross sign over there
hello hey okay let's not do that
so you're on faster by tapping that's
kind of noxious but hey I'm rolling with
it all right
what are we gonna do with this I gots
vandalism I'm not cool with vandalism
sure why don't you do it he doesn't even
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
I guess we have to all right that's
pretty basic feels alright dad a dead
data why my [ __ ] bad teachers man
Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada
sip on us at you I don't know how to do
honor better
I tried all right so we go into the the
jocks hall or whatever
oh hello lady I love mamacita
oh yes she has a boyfriend that's
perfect hey what's up ah okay fine I'm
sorry okay don't hit on girls when their
boyfriend is near all right I got it
why why am i doing everything that this
guy says it make no sense
oh-ho I'm gonna stay in this straight
that's exactly what I'm gonna what are
you gonna do it's gonna sit down and
think about his life Oh [ __ ]
Assassin's Creed up in this [ __ ] ah all
right what's up what's up for jocks
let's get him just for fun Pacquiao and
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you out they die
really quick point guys they're wearing
[ __ ] armor and [ __ ] I don't know what
it's called equipment it shouldn't go
down so easy let's get him - just for
fun
nerd respect what's up ain't no respect
like no respect you don't [ __ ] with
nerds
that's how it is all right go down go
down go down
oh [ __ ] maybe not advocate
hi hey what's up hey what's up hey hey
hey I [ __ ] your mom last night whoops
whoops okay we got oh [ __ ] no oh he
wants to hug me
I don't like hugs um so we need to go to
the stars on their map sort of map how
do I shake the mat okay I think I can
choose my mission from here cuz there's
two stars I guess I don't know what you
want to pick though I guess I picked the
one that's closest doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo all right so we go into the
library I'm gonna guess this is where
the Nerds hang out save algae all right
what's going on
what so you're the new kid what is it oh
talking about you oh are they and what
are they saying
yeah nothing nice pants man sociopath
Gary socio what sociopath it means never
mind forget I said anything okay I need
you to help me
wait why you need me to help you I've
got some library books that need to be
returned but I'm too scared to go to my
locker do I look like a librarian do I
look like a know about your help
pretend you're friends with me close
your pants crazy make it five
no two bucks great five bucks
cool back let's go I love him I wish you
could play as him it's but instead
Darren and I disappear would we call
nerd instead
like rotten gremlins it's really key oh
my god I want to play that game
Wow
wow this guy scores more ladies than I
do what the [ __ ] all right so what am I
supposed to do eh
oh I don't touch it boom in your face
boom boom what sob why this [ __ ] pee
on them they don't care
yeah I want him to pee here we'd be
hilarious
please see here the red running ring
around the clock is your timing oh geez
alright come here I'll get all nan are
you following me or what yes what are
you how did you get that banana oh way
this is twin alright alright well we
have to make him pee okay I really don't
want you to be either it's a cafeteria
where the [ __ ] is the is it here
what is it that's class we should be in
class right now
I guess what is this women bathroom ah
[ __ ] it
ah for [ __ ] sake
would you rather be yourself Wow
fine you know what fine I don't care Oh
hairless all right I'm guessing these
guys want to [ __ ]
don't be something
whoa he's awesome he wants to pay what
nude ahead what the [ __ ] oh the pit if I
finish I hide you better [ __ ] pee why
am I playing this [ __ ] why can someone
explain its - out of order what I why am
I paying Wow Wow
I say that when I pee - really really
though just pee please just know I'd
really don't yeah he's there all right
let's find a bathroom quick as [ __ ]
don't tell me there's no bathroom here
[Music]
I can't believe anyone likes condiments
that's not mayonnaise bro
that's [ __ ] urine all right breasts I
will have genders episode here anyway
like a family
this guy converted a and I thought about
my lovey breath
[Music]
or better that's all take a moment
teabag is wet up here dapat
hello
[Music]
I know I would die in a sexy way I know
it